THE SHOT, RIGHT ON!
THEY SCORE!
AND THE
WE SEE THIS PUCK WHEN IT GOES
OFF HIS IN
FRONT.
BUT NOW ANDERSON.
IT'S RIGHT AGAINST THE POST.
HE'S KNOCKEDE LINE.
THIS SABRES POWER PLAY BROUGHT
TO YOU BY NEW WAVE ENERGY, YOUR
LOCAL ENE CENTER
ICE.
AND THEY SCOREES OUT WITH THE OE
HAND, LIFTS UP THE
ANDERSON WAS RECOVERING FROM THE
SAVE THAT HE THE PUCK.
BARKOV CORNER.
THERE'S THE SHOT, THEY SCORED!
THAT ONE TAPPED RIGHT AT THE
OVER THAT RIGHT PAD OF CRAIG
ANANTING
IN IN FRONT CRAZY AND
THEY'RE BEING  AWAY.
FLIPPED UP IN THE AIR AND PICKED
UP AT CENTER BY
NOWHERE TO GO.
>> Rick: THE PUCK CARRIED IN
OVER T ICE.DUCKS INTO THE CORNE.
IN FRONTNT ACCIARI.
IT'S GOING TO BE WHISTLED DOWN.
TUCH WILL FIRE
>> Rick: FLORIDA WITH HUBERD DC.
HUBERDEAU DOESN'T SHOOT.
RIGHT IN FRONT OF THE NET, HUYS
UP THERE.
HE'S GOING TO BE ABLE TO SLIDEI
INTO THE CORNER AND BROUGHT OUT
BY BENNETT.
BENNETT TO THE BUFFALO LIN NET.
TUCH CLEARED TO THE OTHER SIDE,
IN SLIDE THE
PUCK IN UNDERNEATH HIM.
WEEGARETS IT OVER THE
NET.
AND IT'S BROUGHT AWAY TO S FIGU!
ASPLUND LETS THE SHOT GO FROM
NOT SURE.
MAYBE IT TOUCHED JOHN HAYDEN
HERE GOING TO THE THE SIDE.
OLOFSSON STEALS IT AWAY.
SEND IT TO THE BLUE